[Music]
so so the first lesson is don't kill
motivation you know business businesses
are often not about just increasing it
you just buy stop decreasing it tell you
a story I gave a talk at a company in
Seattle a few years ago it's a big
software company and I was giving giving
a talk and I was in this room with 200
really depressed engineers talking to
them it turns out they were working on
whatever the next version of the they're
working on something really importantly
big for that company and they wish
before I showed up the CEO of that
company came to them and cancelled the
project and they were incredibly
devastated this was a group that worked
for two years on something that they
thought would be the next great thing
for that company in a week before he
just cancelled and they did not show up
on time they were just devastated
they were just morally devastated and by
the way after that many of them just
left the company there were very good
people they were just so demoralized and
I asked him I said okay let's just
assume the CEO had to cancel the project
just assume he had to cancel for
whatever reason let's not question that
what could the CEO have done not to get
you to be so depressed and they came up
with all kinds of ideas they said what
if we allow them to make a few working
prototypes and distribute them within
the company for a few years and just
kind of see what people do it they said
what if he allowed them to take parts of
this new technology they were developing
and see which parts would be useful in
other parts of the organization right
have some kind of leftovers from the
project they said what if he would allow
them to do a workshop for the whole
company to show them the journey of the
last two years what they've accomplished
what they've learned what they struggle
with what they've figured out and the
thing about all of those suggestions all
of them would have needed some time
money and effort right and if the CEO
thinks that those people are just like
rats in a cage is it up I got a told you
to go this way you went this way now I
want to
go somewhere else I'll close that gate
I'll tell you to go somewhere else then
you don't need to worry about motivation
but if you understand that motivation is
incredibly important then you say how do
we get these people who have invested a
lot in this and how we don't just crush
their spirits but what he did was to
crush the spirit so lesson number one is
stop crushing people's spirit and you
know it might seem like a ridiculous
obvious thing to do but if you look at
lots of companies you will see lots of
places where not not because people
intend to do harm but just because we
don't truly appreciate what we're
meaning comes to life we do lots of
those things we get people to start
projects and we cut it in the middle we
get people to prepare presentation and
they never get delivered we do all kinds
of things that that eliminate motivation
imagine we were doing this little video
segment and we knew all along that it
will be good chances will never see the
light of day we'll just never be posted
anything like a black hole where it's
being posted and nobody nobody nobody
will see how exciting we're there to be
you know lots of people are working in
an environment like that now now the
more important question is how do we get
people to be about you know get more
motivation not just stop decreasing
motivation but increasing the sense of
meaning lots of ways to do it and and
maybe the best example is to think about
the open source community one of the
things that happen in the open source
community is that there was a legal
advance where they basically agreed that
everybody who writes a piece of code
their name would always be connected to
it now you could say why who cares
people care if your name is connected to
a piece of code you're going to maintain
that piece of code forever there was a
period in time where people were worried
about getting open source software
because who's going to maintain it if
your name is connected to it you're
going to you're going to maintain it and
indeed people maintain all kinds of
software all kinds of unlikely events
and and people invest in it and knowing
that if I could
ate something and other people build on
it it would always have my name in my
connection and my sense of contribution
is incredibly motivating so just think
about that that simple idea of where do
we put people's names on every piece of
software like why and the hood of the
car all the people who are involved
could you know sign your name in a very
small small print and then of course
there's other things right it's not just
about name association it's about the
feeling of contribution and the feeling
that you ever say autonomy right that
you're not just told what you're going
to do it's that you are doing it there's
a very cute experiment in which they
take kids they come with their mother to
a lab and they go into a separate room
with the research assistant and they do
it drawing together and one time the
research assistant does the drawing and
the kid tells them what to do so the
kids give the instructions and the
research assistant does the mechanical
work another condition the research
assistant gives the instruction and the
kids the kid does the the mechanical
work and then as they finish it the
research assistant take the take the
drawing in their hand go out of the room
first before the kid shows it to the
mother and says look what I did and the
question is when will the kid be more
upset right so so the the rigid this is
a basically takes credit for the kids
job when will the kid be more upset when
the kid did the drawing but the idea was
somebody else or when the idea was the
kid and somebody else did the mechanical
thing and the kids get more upset when
it was their idea which was their idea
think about how much we don't give
credit in this world to other people's
ideas how many people feel that their
ideas were taken somebody else is using
it and they don't get credit credit is
free right credit is great give
everybody credit right there's a team of
100 people give everybody credit why why
not why are we so stingy with giving
people giving people credit anyway
there's lots of other examples like this
we could just say let's look at all the
things that give people a sense of
meaning and let's just try to give more
of it on everyday basis
[Music]